bonsoir fait bien défini pour merci
d'être avec nous en direct par téléphone
quelle est votre réaction à cette
décision soudaine comme l'a décrit jean
rottner
il était plus en plus qu'il ya deux
choses à vista effectivement l'accidenté
de cette décision et son milieu latéral
qui met à mal la coopérative venu
l'essai dans tout le temps d'avoir avec
les länder présent puisque nous sommes
une zone trip frontalière donc avec une
femme travaillant beaucoup il ya
énormément des changes avec le
luxembourg avec la star avec le baptême
de poney même beaucoup beaucoup des
chances pour tous nos territoires c'est
très important
et la deuxième chose qu'il faut quand
même souligner c'est aussi le rôle du
gouvernement parce qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement joue les vierges
effarouchées face à cette décision
allemande mais il ne faut pas oublier
que olivier vêtements puis jean castets
sont beaucoup stigmatiser la moselle en
soulignant sauzens nord s'est réformé
peu de portes que l'arrivée des variants
on a beaucoup pris cet hôtel que dans
d'autres départements dont il est
techniquement le taux d'incidence est à
dire le nombre de cas positifs rapporté
à la population est très élevé mais si
vous prenez l'autre de positivité d'un
modèle est à dire le pourcentage
peut-être positif sur le nombre de tests
effectués il n'est encore moins vite et
en modèle en moyenne dans les autres
départements
donc il ne faut pas stigmatiser la moto
est bien rond ont fait des autres et des
boucs émissaires du président de
territoires ont décrit beaucoup de
difficultés pour nos croyances
alors qu'aujourd'hui la situation
sanitaire ne le justifie absolument pas
absolument plus alors les restrictions
tout cas elles sont quand même copieux
on rappelle que ces concerne 16 mille
travailleurs frontaliers test de
dépistage négatif de -2 48 heures et de
déclarations électroniques d'entrer
enfin c'est surtout pour que le test
c'est compliqué comment ça va se gérer
tout cela est d'ailleurs avec un cours
j'imagine faramineux aussi pour l'état
et la sécurité sociale
oui il y avait obligation de tête et
tout n'était pas encore la dernière mise
d'accord bienvenue en pratique pour
naviguer de façon et longuement à la à
la frontière il ya eu des négociations
sur le dd des tests d'avant il a fallu
faire pression sur le gouvernement pour
qu'il parte notre voie et que les tests
ne soient pas de décrire de quelques
approches à dire effectuer tous les
jours nous nous demande 72 heures pour
tunis a fait que deux fois par semaine
et s'est trouvée pour que ce soit 48
heures heureusement parce que comme vous
les reddick déjà posée quand c'est hyper
contraignant de trouver un créneau pour
faire un tête tous les deux jouent mais
en plus c'est une chose d'extrêmement d'
extrêmement coûteux donc aujourd'hui il
ya un certain nombre de tests est
antinomique
et ça libère peut-être un moment donné
qui vont être mises en place aux
frontières
mais force est de constater
qu'effectivement une bonne partie du
coût reposera sur nom de la sécurité
sociale mais aussi en partie un moment
donné sur les sons les travailleurs sur
les travailleurs eux-mêmes la population
en face les travailleurs savent bien
d'ici lipow comment ils réagissent
aujourd'hui on imagine beaucoup
d'incompréhension et de colère beaucoup
d'incompréhension alors la colère
maintenant avec les mois les mesures
sanitaires qui ont été imposées on a dit
de la moselle la cedh et la plastique à
petit à la résignation sans beaucoup de
résignation et d'agathe mans des gens
effectivement il était déjà à cran ils
le sont encore un petit peu plus parce
que vous l'avez dit les travailleurs
frontaliers pour un département comme le
nôtre cette huile personnes qui m'ont en
allemagne tous les jours mais pas ce
n'est pas une mince affaire
donc il sort à la fois agacé mais aussi
d'un certain côté un peu résignés par
cette histoire du coc vide qui dure qui
dure
et pour ces gens qui travaillent encore
la perspective d'être vacciné de pouvoir
reprendre une vie normale
départ les choix qui sont faits en
france et la stratégie vaccinale un peu
erratique
elle est employée à plusieurs mois
devant nous donc ceux des chefs fournier
a duré malheureusement
pression c'était une impression vous
allez me corriger que finalement nous on
est plutôt assez clément assez souple et
que c'est à l'étranger que c'est le plus
compliqué bien qu'on soit évidemment en
europe on le rappelle qu'en est il des
allemands qui viennent chez nous les
travailleurs allemands et on a peut-être
moins je ne sais pas mais eux ils sont
soumis à des restrictions aussi
drastiques
non bien sûr que non il y en a moins
mais ils sont quand même mais ils sont
quand même là et puis pour compléter le
climat réponse à la question précédente
il savait on a l'habitude dans notre
région de vivre les uns avec les autres
les économies sont imbriquées beaucoup
de gens pour certains produits viennent
d'allemagne faire leurs courses en
france et à linverse pour d'autres
produits les rentrées vont faire leurs
courses en allemagne
donc nous visons les uns avec les autres
de manière interdépendantes et et un
briquet donc la france mais depuis le
début de la crise a souvent par rapport
à à ses frontières c'est preuve
d'angélisme n'a jamais voulu remettre en
cause a beaucoup de moments qui étaient
les facilités de de schengen même comme
ça nous était défavorable et que au
printemps de l'année dernière le virus
pour monter monter très très vite on se
rend compte très bien que les allemands
eux sont plutôt adeptes de la
realpolitik et que quand à court terme
leurs enjeux la rhune leurs intérêts du
pays sont en jeu ils sont capables de
prendre des mesures drastiques sur un
temps très très réduit et qui dans la
vie avec une autrichien avec les
tchèques vous l'avez mentionné et qui
tienne compte avant tout de leurs
intérêts nationaux
au delà de au delà de ces projets de ces
projets européens donc il ne faut jamais
jamais oublier ça et à côté
effectivement n'irai pas jusqu'à parler
de laïcité peut-être encore une fois
nous notre volonté est de travailler
dans la durée avec les voisins allemands
pour la gestion de cette crise parce que
cette interdépendance niveau compagne et
elle bénéficie à nos à nos deux
économies des départements et des länder
ouanna et qu'on a toujours travaillé en
très bonne intelligence
mais quand berlin vient se mêler de
cette affaire là et tape du poing sur la
table et souvent de manière très très
dur une réunion en tout cas se tiendra
demain entre angela merkel et les länder
avec peut-être regarder des
assouplissements c'est ce qu'on vous
souhaite en tout cas en moselle merci à
vous faire des clips pour d'avoir été
aussi beaucoup